[Music]
in racist teacher news no I thought all
teachers were inherently racist they
should be submitted by chicken with
pants that's a dope image a teacher has
reassigned after being called out for a
racist podcast she hosted as a hobby
what is it
what kind of racism is it like I blame
the racist
or is it like subtly is it just is it
like like jinx I hate movies or some
[ __ ] like yeah what is it I know it's
not super blatantly racist hey I guess
it would be a little bit more subtle
sorta so anyway this teacher she's a
Florida middle school teacher her name
is Dan Jana and she had a white
supremacist podcast called unapologetic
and she was also she also had a Twitter
account that was pretty racist and there
was a lot of auntie's anti-semitic posts
and so now recently she has handed in
her resignation after like huffington
post posted like this whole
investigation on her and they hooked her
up yeah they hooked her out so this is
what she really good laugh
unapologetic carnal y'all gonna know her
she's 25 looks like a teacher like
Cubano or does she lightweight blade
yeah [ __ ] hate herself that's what I'm
like how can she be why some premises
where she doesn't look her her face gets
bigger at the bottom so it starts off
with a small just gets bigger and bigger
bigger like a pair and she has a browse
on the side of her eyes how the [ __ ]
does that happen
you didn't really read it looks like a
freaking biker handlebar wait what's her
last name again cuz it does not sound
white it sounds ethnic her last bullet
wait bullets its vol I Russians on a pH
right because it looks like polish
shirts like Eastern European yeah she
looks mixed with something so cuz if you
ask like the white purists should they
probably wouldn't consider her white
yeah yeah just because of the fact she's
not blonde blue-eyed the other like
angles I don't think you have to be
white to be racist against other
ethnicities well it's funny that's it's
a white supremacist not a polar
supremacy that's true could create
Clayton Bigsby remember the blind Dave
Chappelle's behind KKK he was black and
he was racist and then he divorced his
wife marrying a black guy that's not the
words he chose but I guess I'm not gonna
say what he said hey no say it though
what did you what'd he say you gotta
watch that okay so it's not my word to
use is it really like some hate [ __ ] I'm
gonna play snippets of her podcast but I
just also wanted to mention that she
went by this
Tianna dull top tiana is the most
non-white name ever better thank ya
Nicki Patterson Becca she doesn't like a
Becky looks like a Becky [ __ ] straight
oh my god Becky look at the size of her
look at her brows all right so this is
clips from a podcast that's just the way
it is there are there are reasons that
have higher IQs and than others because
New Orleans is there's quite a huge
African population there and it's this
engrained hunter-gatherer culture that
left them unprepared for Hurricane
Katrina
I had one has no watch me old the
principal over my head and you know told
her I'm worried that your teacher is in
you know she's injecting local bias into
her teaching and the principal came to
me and she was like I'm not worried
should I be worried and I'm like no
she's so stupid I think she puts it on a
podcast I think I think she's so stupid
I can't even like clown on her because
she already just did it to herself yeah
some of us tweets oh my god it isn't
supremacist or hateful to prefer your
own people over others that's exactly
what that means
yeah definition supremacy and she looked
up the word oh my god
social studies huh don't you know that
the taco supreme is better than the
regular taco yeah come on yeah that's
what supremacist yeah it's better than
the other ones that's why you got to get
the pop of supreme when you happy and
you think that your group is the best
that is a supremacist yeah what an idiot
dude never better talked about she also
doesn't understand English
other tweet says you know America's
education system is designed to enable
victim and victimization when teachers
are forced to learn about institutional
racism and prove it's real when it isn't
I literally feel brain cells dying as I
read this [ __ ]
hashtag Sunday morning she literally
feels it you don't [ __ ] literally
feel [ __ ] you idiot you literally feel
that you can't let your brain cells you
even know what it feels like brain cell
[ __ ] stupid she has some like
outdated as Jim Crow education [ __ ] like
those black people there are too similar
to those you know living in huts and all
that and it's like dude you're [ __ ]
dumb you know how many like Nigerian
immigrants come here and they are
getting into Ivy League's and like they
are really killing it right now and it's
like how can you even say that disgrace
to her community her race and her gender
I dare you look like a Mexican you come
down there she's making all the Cubans
look bad all of us yeah the the headline
thing in her photo itself confronting
racism in classrooms that's what she's
talking about other tweet says apologize
for my absence Twitter can find me in
Twitter jail for the second time this
week for educate for educating people on
the floors of hashtag Islam let's see if
they make me delete this sweep to place
your bets
how many follow the chef that she's like
talking it's like audience yeah this
round audience up like three people
they're like a brother or sister no mom
no people on instagram that have like 80
followers and they do Instagram live Oh
are they post five times a day yeah and
they're like on Instagram live I kind of
want to join the live session be like
hey turn that [ __ ] off
nobody's here yeah the rest of the
followers are [ __ ] BOTS yeah I'm
sorry to tell you that it's like what in
the [ __ ] it's like did you not know
Instagram Live was not made for you it
was made for people who had a lot of
followers my god
that so much yeah and so she came out
after this whole thing went viral with
the media just everyone's reporting the
fact that she's this racist ass teacher
she comes out and says it was satirical
I was just kidding over and over and
over and over and over and over and over
again yeah yeah she's lame if she was
known to be a troll I guess but I mean
you're a teacher she said it was
political satire and exaggeration and
the persona was just a she's not what
about the swastika on her back it's a
but I don't
moment for her Jesus yeah she's a method
actor yeah you know I mean yeah
statement none of the statements
released about my being a white
nationalist or white supremacists have
any truth to them nor are my political
beliefs injected into my teaching of
social studies curriculum we are seeing
bits and pieces though to that we are
nowhere in that where she's like talking
about my income for like [ __ ] Heil
Hitler she's not saying anything that's
related to Nazism or white supremacist
like it doesn't say like well that's why
I said it wasn't latent racism like it
was like sprinkled in there like she
she's definitely stupid for sure yeah
that's not your podcast I do too I kind
of I'm kind of curious just because like
if I know it'll be good comedy the
funnier thing is it's like do you know
that in [ __ ] 1880 you are not
considered white yeah you know what I
mean like it's like if anyone saw you on
the street back then they wouldn't
consider her white it was stoned you ya
curly-haired [ __ ] no schools she works
at our ninety percent white students
four percent black and 3% Hispanic in
Florida Laurie
no it's I mean the idea of white has
changed too because you know like the
Rat Pack they were considered minorities
back in a day like Frank Sinatra Italian
right or a part of time yeah I mean
Italians Irish Jewish they were all
considered minorities back then which
were but now they're under the the white
umbrella so I mean it always changes the
definition changes I'm pretty sure one
day you know it's gonna be so different
- it's like light skin or dark skin I
hope not I hope it never gets to that it
was like other countries that are like
that cuz it's all blend in yeah
thank God yeah she's influencing the the
very influential minds man especially
because she even mentioned in her
podcast ik Oh the principal actually
believe me like she's obviously in
that's a terrible that just seems like
factual like she's talking about excerpt
out of her life
yeah a parent felt the need to go over
the teachers head and go straight to the
principal like she's obviously teaching
these kids I'm sure would you be so
angry as a parent to go into a school
not maybe not into a school but find a
teacher that's gonna [ __ ] them up for
him on your kids behalf depends on what
they did I guess I mean I wouldn't rule
that option out but I would want to know
what happened for some kids spit on my
kid alright let's say your your that
t-shirt basically I don't know [ __ ]
spit on your kid like and call them a
[ __ ]
oh it's like you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
depends on my kid teacher [ __ ] pinch
the [ __ ] out of my shoulder and I went
home and I told my mom and she spanked
me because she knew I probably did
something and I look back and I probably
deserved the [ __ ] out of that yeah she
pinched the [ __ ] out of my shoulder like
beat the [ __ ] out of you yes because I'm
like you little [ __ ]
but then I'd go to that teacher and be
like if you ever [ __ ] touch my kid
again I'm gonna [ __ ] kill you
exactly that's right I will go to this a
little bit I would've gave my teacher I
would've gave the teacher a high-five
now you wouldn't hey
yeah I'll be like [ __ ] up cuz I couldn't
do it cuz I made a vow not to do it
oh you're gonna strangers it you're just
hell yeah I want them to fear the world
wait what
how can they grow up thinking anybody
can attack no but then I will empower
them with the knowledge of weapons
martial arts and all kinds of stuff so
like it's gonna be awesome if it's gonna
be a spectacle yeah it's gonna be
pay-per-view it's gonna be awesome
[Laughter]
watch it's like The Truman Show right
watch it I'm waiting dude world is going
to see Hit Girl and real ly not be
awesome it's gonna be like Chris
Hanson's 20/20 but then we turn it
around and we close the gates and then
we go who's gonna survive the pedophile
oh my daughter and then like they fight
it out and then she comes and she wins
with exact cyborg he's like cyborg like
[Music]
[Music]